I heard that jins and tlor are going
to
[Music]
what hi everyone I'm Jinx Monsoon and
I'm Benda LA crem and I'm Jinx Monsoon
and we're here to read some thirsty
tweets and I don't quite know what to
expect I do because I may have sent some
thirst Tweets in my day specifically at
Eric Andre if they were from you I would
know what to expect just imagine it's me
writing about us these are going to be
completely baked out I want to be in a
thruple with bendelac Creme and Jinx
Monsoon claiming it is claiming it
calling dibs because yeah I bet somebody
called dibs already this is starting
with the misconception that we're
banging we have
never no it's true we don't sound
convincing but it's true the mommy
issues too Jinx Monsoon is my absolute
favorite person in the world pipeline
asking for someone who is definitely not
me they're saying that if you have mommy
issues then that leads you to jinx
Monsoon is my absolute favorite person
in the world oh yes that's by Design
listen I have mommy issues myself why do
you think I created this character I can
attest daa's body ravenous animal noises
what would that sound
like Tasmanian devil
exactly I think they mean
like but that's not that's not what I
imagine I just need to say one thing
Jinx monson's ass and her hips are my
Roman Empire they're available online
exactly shout out to astroboy tocom
they've been providing my ass and hips
for
years daa is a mil I have mommy issues
oh good we get to share the mommy issue
people yeah I mean I lean into being a
mom when did you have kids I am not
aware I must have left some behind while
I was on the road traveling if I have
any kids out there feel free to contact
me and she is not maternal no I'm really
not it's I feel free to contact me I
can't say I'll write back this was says
I can't believe I just realized how much
I love and admire Jinx Monsoon her mind
is so powerful I want a lick her face or
something that's typically how I show my
appreciation for intellect as well when
I really like a
book all my favorite professors in
college just lapped them right up this
isn't all caps Bendel laem owns my MF
curves um how do you own a curve thank
you well I own the deed to the curve now
so deed I had a sex dream with bendelac
crem in and out of drag and I'm not even
mad like a threesome oh there was Ben
and daa I think so on either end I think
Ben is better in bed than daa daa's just
tights from here down her Anatomy is
lacking just like a couch cushion her
mother was a couch and her father was
Miss
Piggy roses are red green is the grass
Jinx Monsoon owns this gay homo ass
there's a lot of ownership I know do you
want to Parlay your ownership of that
one person's curves with um shed
ownership of my ass I just absolutely
let's do it let's let's conglomerate
this is fun this is like Monopoly did
anyone else want to Bendle a CR wow
they're just coming right out no Rhymes
no green is the grass all right
parentheses drag race or was it just me
not the other
bendem who's known for football I mean I
can tell you just from these tweets it
is not just you so get in line buddy me
taking a deep breath before screaming at
a new hot picture of jinx when do I post
hot pictures that must have been a while
ago I don't post anything sexy most my
post are sure you do you hold your
camera up here and you do that thing
where you engage all your face muscles
like this it's very
sexy so uh Bend crem how can I step my
[__] up as hard as letter you do you
want to start waking up that early cuz
we had to wake up at 6:00 a.m. today to
step our [__] up yes you think these
[__] just step themselves up no we
had you think we wake up with stepped up
[__] no NOP we had to glue them down
covered into those [__] have been
through the
ringer here let's show this phone I
can't hand you anything I'm corseted can
some [__] with crystals shove them up
their vagina and manifest that jinx
tells me she loves me or however you do
it well I just saw something about this
you should not be sticking things up
your vagina that have not been approved
to be up there who's approval do you
okay apparently there was like an online
Trend where people were shoving
malachite dildos up there malachite it's
a type of stone and anyway they were
getting copper poisoning Gwyneth peltro
why did you start this we've been gooped
not to be straight trademark but I would
literally let Bend La Creme destroy my
vagina I'm not making that face a vagina
I'm making it a destroy like I'm you
have a Lely vagina I want to protect it
there's times where you just want to be
wrecked I get it but I'm just going to
I'm going to build it a a sweet little
Nest I'm going to feed it milk out of a
bottle and just pet it and keep it to
what like you nurse a bird back to
health or whatever it hasn't been
destroyed yet though you'd have to first
destroy and then nurse well I don't know
when this tweet came out it could have
been destroyed by now continue Jinx is
such a lady such a mother such a sexy
mom like for real she's the youngest
narcoleptic mil and show business a
title that no one's trying to compete
with me for except did you know that
Cindy loer is narcoleptic she might be
the number one narcoleptic mil and I get
number two oh wow okay all right Bendel
crem I had a dream that we had set while
you were in full drag I was the top
which is confusing since I have no dick
you can still be a top and have no dick
you cannot however have sex with DEA and
drag as we said though because there are
no orifices these are painted on get in
this nostril
baby this person says Bend to the creme
I'm just a hole kind of makes you wonder
how they learned how to tweet it means a
lot that you would confide in me that
way I have a little nest in a bottle to
so with your name on it and the name is
co Jinx could stab me to death and I
would just be like a that was adorable I
love her I can't imagine myself stabbing
anymore oh I can it would have to be
like really dramatic or it could just be
at an airport I'm a [__] at airports is
what she's trying to say I could
accidentally stab someone totally that
probably already happened I want Bend La
Creme to stab me in the throat with a
high heeled chew why does everyone want
to be stabbed so much what happened to a
peck on the cheek and a walk around the
park and a high heel is relatively blunt
when it comes to stabbing that would
take a long time what happened to an
under the table hand job like these
people want to be stabbed to death this
is jinx has big [__] Destroyer energy
this is probably the most accurate thing
she rips them right off they're on my
altar she keeps them amongst her
crystals I'd let bendelac crem double
dip me hash # NGL what's NGL that's not
going to lie I don't know what double
dip me and then # RuPaul does that mean
is that who's double dipping are they
double dipping in me and rup Paul if I'm
using G exclus does double dip mean go
from one hole to the next oh it is look
at me no wow that okay just these two
just back and forth no you going to bang
them out like real oh I'm supposed to
double dip them all right warm up those
RuPaul cuz RuPaul's going to be sitting
there watching if you enjoyed watching
us do that imagine watching us do
something scripted that we put work into
absolutely come and check out the Jinx
and de la holiday show which is coming
to a theater near you until the new year
you have all of December to see us and
if you haven't seen us yet just travel
to where we're going to be cuz we do it
so why can't you Mary whatever you
[Music]
celebrate